now I think the interesting thing about
this is to say well it is doing
compression it's doing a pretty good job
and you can look at Lempel Ziv
compressed text it's almost routinely
compressible down to shall we say 20% of
its size by using techniques like this
text is very compressible stuff because
it's actually very very predictable as
indeed Claude Shannon found out what we
are saying is we're not introducing any
probability model behind this about
characters or about words we're letting
it in a sense establish its own
probability model some of you may find
this rather strange because if you refer
back to a previous video you will now
have seen we covered the topic of how to
devise a Huffman tree given a set of
probabilities and on the sheet of paper
here which sean has available on his
computer so it goes be inserted you
might protest and say well why not do it
even better here are all the characters
from A to Z let's presume our book or
our text is all in lowercase all in
uppercase so all we have to do is write
down all 27 characters find out how
frequently they occur inside our book or
our piece of text here are the
probabilities they do all add up to 1 in
the end I'll show you and here a great
programming expense that Crabbe actually
worked out what the Huffman code would
be for each of these characters notice
that the most common character is the
inter word space gap 0.18 next most
common is e and then of course T a and
so on so based on those probabilities my
automated Huffman tree program has come
out with this set of Huffman codes some
of them are caused very short for common
things some of them for things like so
very very long so I said well surely if
that's optimal in some sense
why not apply to this why do it this way
well the answer is those are a perfectly
good set of probabilities if only when
you're reading you read one character at
a time but you don't you group
characters into sequences and these
probabilities alter dramatically when
you get sequences of characters I think
one of my favorite illustrations of this
which I can give you from here is of how
if you like relative probabilities are
according to this table here the
probability of encountering the letter U
is 0.02 to 8 in other words it's 2.3
percent probable to occur however in
English what you can also say those if
you've done probabilities will know this
notation I'll say very slowly for those
who aren't so familiar the probability
of seeing a u in general in arbitrary
text is 2.3 percent but what is the
probability of seeing a you even that
you've just seen a queue and the answer
is certainly in English I would say
Shawn I both agree on this
well greater than 99% there are very
very few words in English where you just
get a queue on its own not full of IOU
there's some examples of course Brady
will know one of these really well
acronyms Qantas Queensland and Northern
Territory's air service alone cube
without you names of countries Iraq but
apart from country names craniums
abbreviations you do not get many cues
that aren't followed by you except qi
for those Scrabble enthusiasts why Oh
what does Qi mean ah
[Music]
Toula to go edwards trouble alright will
allow qi occasionally Scrabble the
scrabble dictionary has got it
but I think the point should be clear
it's all constantly shifting sands these
abilities you can't say that those
carrots probabilities are absolute in
any sense they shift about all over the
place depending on the structure of the
words and even more deadly is the fact
that we as humans regard our
probabilities in word units not in
character units and all the time the
probability of something happening is
very very strongly related to what has
gone previously that we were discussing
Sean and I just recently consider the
phrase one of Elvis's first records was
don't you step on my blue suede and with
probability 99.999% and it's worthy
shoes this happens all the time and the
surprise factor if you like in natural
languages and in English is not very
high indeed so things like the Lempel
Ziv method build on that they don't say
oh we'll take some pre given set of
probabilities not even four words what
it says is we will implicitly establish
our own probabilities by seeing how
often certain strings keep occurring
inside this file and if they occur a lot
you will find lots and lots of back
pointers to commonly occurring words so
in a sense what it's saying implicitly
is that the combination Co MPU ter
occurs again and again and again and
again in this particular document but it
might not occur for example nearly so
often in something like a Charles
Dickens novel so there's huge
flexibility to be gained by letting the
compressor either explicitly or
implicitly
of the statistics of the occurrence as
it goes along in what's sometimes called
generally adaptive compression models
you might want to also look up one of
the ultimate techniques in adaptive
compression called arithmetic
compression and that is a huge topic in
its own right
the probabilities may not be what they
first seem and if you say to me what's
the secret behind information theory and
compression the answer is all the time
probabilities probabilities
probabilities the three P's getting your
probability model right for the material
you are coping with is the heart of
getting a really successful compression
so all the time you have to be prepared
to be adaptive and even a little bit
pragmatic because many compression
methods will say hmm if I were to do it
to pass process on this look at the
statistics really learn about them then
come back and then do the compression I
could get a few percent better results
than just trying to compress it as a go
long do you want me to do that and my
reply would be well we're going to tell
you an extra half hour to compress it
and decompress it I'm not interested I'd
sooner have a sort of 95 percent okay
compression that's quick to decompress
and the great thing about Lempel Ziv is
it is fast to decompress and that really
really matters